all right so welcome to the modern
Benoni is no baloney
part 2 you can thank mr. Brent Simon for
that title and today we'll just get
right to it let's jump over to the board
and we'll be looking over lines we're
white in this position okay we'll just
remind ourselves to the first few moves
in this position we play c5 just
attacking the center and okay they
almost always invariably play the move
d5 grab a little bit more space and now
we attack the center not with b5 but
with a six this is what we're looking at
today the modern Benoni and so okay
after Knight to c3 they're thinking
about playing e4 but we can capture
first and play d6 and we get sort of to
the very starting point of the lecture
and last week we went over you know the
very aggressive lines with E 4 and F 4
and trying to play e5 really early and
crush black so we went over that and
tonight we're going to go over something
a little bit different we're going to
look at lines with E 4 and Knight f3
although we will look at one line two
with a knight go somewhere else but
we're basically looking at E 4 and
Knight f3 which you know you still have
F 4 in mind but you're gonna develop
your pieces and Castle and then you'll
get on with your your middle game plans
and in our last lecture which will be
next Monday we're going to look at lines
where white delays playing e4 so such as
the fianchetto variation and we'll go
over a few others ok so we begin with
the movie for tonight and after g6 it's
actually interesting the classical line
begins with Knight f3 though recently
people have tried to avoid playing this
move immediately and the reason is in a
lot of lines black will play the move
Bishop to g4 and take the knight just
simply put the bishop actually isn't
usually that
great on c8 he often can find himself
without a job especially if white you
know plays a move like h3 before he
plays Knight f3 it's just hard for him
to find anything to do and as we'll
we'll notice you know the more games you
watch in the Benoni White has this very
common maneuver where the knight heads
to c4 and from c-4 he puts some pressure
on the center you can be combined with
his Bishop to attack the D pawn you know
it helps them whenever he wants to play
the move e5 so very often black is
trying to play lines with an early
Bishop to g4 intending to take the
knight however we'll start tonight with
the classical variation which I think in
general is a good spot to start whenever
you're covering any opening because the
classical variation is normally people
develop their pieces and castle and they
do just the most sensible logical things
in the position and from there people
deviate and so to understand the
deviations you want to understand what
happens if we just play normal moves
okay I develop my bishop you develop
your bishop and we castle so this is the
classical variation which although not
super popular now it has been played
recently by a Fabiano Cara Juana so we
will see a game in just a second between
Levon Aronian and Cara Juana that was
played just three months ago which was
you know for the time of the filming
it's it's March was the March 2016 is
when the game was played it was played
in the candidates match so a very
important game and you know he busts out
the benoni rook e8 and in general this
is blacks plan often he combines it with
moves like Knight B to d7 he's really
trying to prevent the e5 push so work he
ate you know very normal and Knight to
d2 so we see the knight he's on his
journey white intends to safeguard the
center with f3 and the knight goes to c4
this is the typical maneuver for white
and the most popular move here is
actually Knight to a6
however Caruana played a different move
so we'll we'll come right back to that
and the point of this move is to
maneuver the knight to c7 when then
we're just we're trying to be able to
play the move beef
five because in the endgame you know
we're trying to push our puns over here
on the queenside so after you guard your
EEP on night c7 and if you immediately
go to c-4 well then thanks to my knight
here I have to move b5 okay so a for the
typical way of preventing blacks
counterplay on the Queen side and just
to give you an idea of how the mainline
goes it's actually interesting because
you'll notice this guy doesn't have a
very bright future so the most common
maneuver is actually to play b6 and
after the knight goes to c4 you know
Bishop a6 with the idea of in many lines
taking this Knight
so that's also why you can see earlier
in the variation sometimes with the
lines where you get to pin the knight
and then take it you can understand I
mean this that's what this Bishop
usually is ending up doing anyway so
that's sort of the basic starting point
here and after this move like as a
couple different moves h6 Queen d7 and
so here's sort of a starting point of
the classical variation however I do
want to bring your attention to this
position and to see what Caruana played
in this position here he played you know
another very logical move Knight B to d7
okay it doesn't get much more logical
than that the knight almost almost
always goes here you know you're just
you're on the e5 square a couple times
white will eventually play f4 and try to
play e5 so the knight makes a lot of
sense on d7 all right and in this
position what also is interesting is now
Aronian played a sideline a4 and f4 are
very common moves here he played them to
move Queen to c2 which also has the
benefit of guarding the e pawn and he
has a very specific idea in mind and
it's a very scary class tonight because
there's a lot of thunder I don't know if
it picks up on the camera but Bensimon
add a bunch of thunder sound effects
because it may make it a really scary
lecture
okay 1985 was played the idea is to play
against Knight to c4 and you are cord a
sort of encouraging white to go ahead
you say yeah it goes f4
you know come get me and you know FF for
know we would have seen no is he just
going to keep going here which seems
very typical was he just going to drop
back and and try to provoke you into it
what was he going to do
but Aronian played this move b3 which is
a sideline within this sideline but Cara
Juana said oh yeah I looked at this
before I does seem a little bit
dangerous so I had a look at it so even
when you you know you play the sidelines
within the sidelines within sidelines
applied lines car Awana is still ready
and prepared like I mean it's he's a
hard guy to out prepare and the real
reason for showing this game has nothing
to do with the actual game it has to do
with the press conference the press
conference for this game was so amazing
that in the next interview the Caruana
did the first question they asked them
was like oh tell me about that press
conference how did you feel about that
so okay it was an excellent press
conference and what I really liked about
it was both players really embodied sort
of the the spirit oh it is raining just
just in time at the spirit of the
opening and it really was how people
really think when they're playing in
these positions cuz Aronian with white
every move he's like yeah I wanted to
sack this sack this act and he's like
why are you giving away all your stuff
you know but he's like cuz I want to
checkmate you and that's how white feels
whenever you play the benoni they want
to checkmate you that's what they're you
know I'm gonna annihilate you crush you
wipe you off the board destroy you and
Karl wanna you know much like a benoni
player was just he's a very calm guy in
general and he's like yeah here I think
you know it's aggressive but I think
you're overestimating your attack and
okay I'm up to ponds and blah blah so
it's actually very interesting just to
see it and that's that's sort of how you
have to be you have to be sort of a
resilient defender to play some of these
positions because they do get quite
scary it's not for the faint of heart
some of these positions and we'll get to
one position here in just a minute
but here he had this novelty prepared
Bishop to g4 so yeah he already had this
like ready to go within the
nobody's ever played this but in the
couple games that were played the move
that the black is always chosen here is
very interesting and it's you know the
sort of move that you kind of want to
look for in this position you got to be
sort of a creative imaginative player if
you want to play the benoni as either
side g5 and the idea is to maneuver the
Knight to f4 you're preventing white
from playing the move f4 so something
like this has been played in the past
and so I guess Caruana probably had a
look at it and decided he wanted to go
with something a little bit different
though this this I mean this obviously
is interesting and then I go step four
and who knows maybe it's black that's
attacking so but we go back alright
Bishop g4 this is what he prepared and
he's saying okay play off three you know
he sounded like provoking f3 and the
reason he's probably doing this is we
know this Bishop is going over here so
if you do put a move like f3 on the
board you are weakening some dark
squares we can imagine in the future you
know Bishop might be able to jump in
here and you know this Bishop is going
off out the other doors so there's he
didn't see any reason to really weaken
his position he's you know play a four
you know at some point but here he just
took which as he said in the press
conference should give him just a slight
advantage and okay he was happy with
that and he's gonna play moves like h3
f4 and he's gonna go crush you know
Americas you know best player so okay so
he does it f4 very scary stuff you know
we're forced back and okay you know it's
kind of scary up here
you knew this in calmly after here okay
attacks the d6 pawn and okay so the
actual it's beyond theoretical interest
so I want to jump to some of the real
cool part in this position after here
he's trying to safeguard the e5 square
this actually is an interesting you know
positional sacrifice that white can
often make in these situations so you do
need to be prepared for this
it's it's now a well-known idea so I'm
sure both players were you know not
surprised by this but what a white play
in this position see if we can get the
the audience involved a little bit yeah
he played a five okay so we I mean we
basically have to accept this this
sacrifice and how would you follow up
here cuz okay if white just takes then
you know of our pieces are so great you
know this one make too much sense we
would just take back and also letting us
take here probably doesn't make sense
either because now the bishop once again
has been liberated so so f5 in the point
of this pawn sacrifice is well these two
guys now are bad pieces hey Arjun is
that you got something for me I got it
for Mike he's not here don't you might
come back you never know I'll hold onto
it for him in case
lol see like I'm wondering do you want
to do dual commentary with me tomorrow
and what uh maybe your game with Darien
maybe the game you play tonight maybe
your best game whatever your best games
are we'll talk about it
you don't know well if you do it I'll
add a month on to your family membership
huh that's a great deal alright alright
alright so expect me I expect dual
commentary with origin to come up
tomorrow night
yeah cuz otherwise I don't know what I'm
doing it okay so in this position you
know we've just Accra Feist upon to you
know make black have some bad pieces
here but also you have the e4 square for
the white night the night goes to e4
we're thinking about playing f6 and then
digit it to checkmate that's the plan
and that's sort of how how white
typically thinks in these sorts of
positions and I do want to get to one
critical point here so b5 I mean you
have to sort of lash out break away the
center even though it's you know it's
again but you need to do something
before white starts attacking you you
got to get some pressure in the center
pressure on the Queen side so you just
ignored it
you know yeah it was not interested in
opening up anything on the queenside
even if you went upon Knight to e4 and
on cue the rain is really pouring can
you add less of rain sound effects and
thunder and you prefer not to you know
make it make it really scary okay so
he's thinking here about playing f6 and
so after this move it's actually
interesting so here it was the most
impressed upon the press conference in
the game he played Bishop to c1 but he
went over this line he showed this one
line oh I was thinking here here here
and he was like yes yes yes checkmate
checkmate
you know I couldn't see how to stop it
but he he in the end ended up not
trusting his intuition but he could play
a combination here and it's really
mostly about planning I'll give you guys
a chance but I put in on the newest
versions of Komodo and stockfish and
when you first play this move with white
it's like all black is like crushing you
you know - 2 - 3 black is you know just
winning but you just keep going move by
move and suddenly it's like oh yeah
white really is winning so even the
computers didn't really see it at first
and he ended up you know not pulling the
trigger and actually going through with
it so I do want to give the audience a
chance you know what would be the
winning plan here already which is it's
sort of hard to imagine and hopefully
you guys have a lot of imagination and
you're able to come up with it yeah this
is very similar yes on the game he
played Bishop c1 immediately f6
and your idea here is just to go here
so if here then you intended to play
here and then and then you're gonna
you're going to put your queen here I
saw I guess I have to go like here or
something and then and then and then
you're going to go here and check me me
okay so very interesting idea good thing
I don't I don't have to go here yeah you
can play here and so this was analyzed
the f6 was the first idea but yeah Cara
wanna said okay I intended to play
Bishop f8 here and now it is mostly -
it's a plan how would you make that King
how can you rearrange your pieces to
checkmate the black king here it's not
so easy do you have another idea okay so
you're going here where's your queen
going means going to c1 and then you put
your Bishop here you're gonna trade
bishops and check me me I do get a lot
of moves though if you have to get some
free moves I mean because I am also
starting to like pick up your stuff oh
and even if you go here I'm just taking
that Oh guys you want to go all the way
over here uh we're gonna try to take it
all right I'm sure I have a defense here
that's set to figure it out
I suppose I can go here jack and here so
do you want to go and play rook you play
King each one would you like to trade
and I'm sure there's you know there's
better defense here but uh okay you're
so you're slipping around you don't want
to trade with me Arjun okay I agree with
that I don't know looks like I have some
defense if I play here will you later
play g4 and make me okay
then I will do that cuz I gave you the
idea okay and something like this though
- there should be some defense here and
I'm I'm sure of Caruana was here he'd be
like no no no defense defense defense
defensive because that's how the entire
press conference was but okay this let's
see so this did happen Bishop f8 and now
the idea for white which is quite
brilliant is h4 h5 and taking then if
you take with the F pawns sometimes you
have to worry about this so we can
imagine we have to take back this way
and then we just need to get our Queen
to the h-file
you know any way possible night here
checkmate so that was his idea so he
thought about this move h4 and so in the
press conference - you know he was
playing white Cara Wan was playing black
and he said okay yeah but I just take
this and he was like okay yeah and he's
like you know what he doing you're just
giving away all your pawns but he's like
you know I go here I go here computer
still says black you know starting
starting to realize but it doesn't get
it yet Queen b3 this all this is a very
interesting way to do it pending the
night the Queen's come in over you know
he's like okay I go here I prevent clean
h3 and Aronian said alright I'll go here
and okay I'm gonna go to the H file one
way or the other and he said I'll take
this right I'll just take stuff because
I'm you know obviously for Grandmaster
so I just take all your stuff and then
you don't checkmate me and here's still
the computers like blacks like better
but it no longer thinks blacks winning
but we're sorry that White's winning but
it'll it'll realize in a second and if
Queen h4 which seems like the most
logical move
it's actually a mistake because after
any move when you play here check and we
trade the Queen's the black wins so he
had this this clever move Queen h2 a
very similar idea the threat now is
Knight to g5 computer is like okay it's
equal you know no big deal yeah queen g4
and so this you know this was blind that
the computer gives it's a line that you
know super grandmaster gives but now
after this move which even the computer
doesn't see even in this position it
didn't see it but then you put it on
there and it's like oh yeah wait switch
the swings and then and then black gives
away all of his pieces back so and then
he was here and yet Caruana was like
looking at it for a second he's like oh
yeah let's check me yeah yeah this is
this is hard to stop without you know
parting with your queen you know you
know the computer wants to like give
this away and then you sack your queen
for the rook and it's like well you know
it's only like +10 for white or
something
ah it's not checkmate but yeah so this
this was it but he ended up not going in
for this variation and it's you know
it's kind of it's one thing to see it
too but then it's another to actually go
through with it in this position you
know just because you are giving away
all of your stuff if there is some
defense that you're not seeing you lose
like that'sthat's the game but okay I
mean it actually did work he he could
have done it he could have won a really
important game and you know then the
press conference would have been much
different but okay we continue in the
game ended on spectacularly after here a
few more moves
he took here if you take here then just
rook d1 but after this very concrete
move
well you're preventing f6 but also after
here now you can take on d6 the point
being that if you play rook d1 I can now
just take this and here I'd have two
rooks for the Queen and then you know
couple extra pounds and you know very
nice position
so instead in this position okay we went
here attacking the rook and we got a
draw uh yeah so you know I guess they
were they were done you know we played
the Pannonian we had our fun yeah it's a
draw so yeah an opportunity missed
perhaps by Aronian would have been a
very exciting game but but okay you know
and if you can play this against Aronian
in the candidates game and then you're
sitting out there and you're telling me
like no this is baloney it's like what I
mean yeah cuz Caruana can play it okay
we return so that was a brief interview
yeah interlude into the classical
variation so let's look one more time
here about the immediate Knight to f3 in
this position and in most lines what
black is trying to do is to put his
bishop here but if he goes there
immediately this is actually a mistake
so if you were white what would you guys
play in this position h3 okay and in the
immortal words of Mike comer I wasn't
bluffing I'm not bluffing and that's a
joke only Bensimon will get and so this
was sort of my strategic point you can
take back I wasn't ending on just taking
your knight so it's the same - if you
play Bishop to e2 not bluffin I just
take it and we black realizes his
strategic goal which was preventing that
night that night usually is quite good
over here on c4 my bishop usually isn't
doing all that much I get that you know
bishops are generally better than
Knights but in this exact position that
is the trade I did want to make so okay
I mean how are you gonna how you going
to stop me from realizing my goal which
one bishop check okay I will go here I
still intend to take your knight and
perhaps this will help me out because
maybe I can play here a lot faster now
so not quite
it is generally in blacks favor to trade
especially all the minor pieces and get
into any major piece ending and the
reason is it's really easy for him to
make a pass pawn on the Queen side with
his majority over here and white if he
ever makes a pass pawn it's going to be
in the center and so in a King and pawn
ending you know just a pure ending there
it's actually the fact that their
outside is actually quite useful usually
for black so in blacks interest if we
could just take all the minor pieces off
the board in this position he'd be happy
to do it and then you should be better
which is sort of an interesting fact
about the position so I'm not really
afraid of trading too much stuff but the
key move here
Queen to a for this this disrupts me a
little bit if I block with a knight well
now you have time to move your knight to
d2 and black has to be a little bit
careful that he doesn't lose this bishop
if on the other hand you go with the
bishop we can move our queen to any
useful square b3 Queen c2 also is
probably fine and okay you got to defend
this pawn and then Mike and I can still
realize my middle gameplan of
maneuvering my knight around so black
goes back to this position okay you got
to come up a little little cunning way
maybe I can get away with with Bishop to
g4 and you actually have this
interesting move a six with the
positional threat d5 and white almost
automatically stops this and now you can
just go through with the maneuver and
there's there's no Queen a4 check so
this is very clever and yeah if you go
here I'm not bluffing
I take your knight so very good and then
you know this is just sort of a small
strategical success for black and this
Knight usually is very good
the knight that can go to c4 both for
checkmating attacks and pressure on the
center and stopping all sorts of blacks
counter play so this is has been a small
success for black the opening which is
why some players with white you know
they've approached this position from a
slightly different angle they
say okay if I play night after
immediately you'll play a six and Bishop
g4 and maybe it can be a little bit more
cunning as white and players have played
moves such as Bishop d3
h3 as likely to transpose you can play
h3 and then Knight f3 but we'll just
cover the the more popular line even
though h3 scores like a lot better a lot
better even though it always transposes
so it's kind of strange and now yeah so
you know now this this move doesn't make
as much sense when I have an idea
so here and we're going to look at the
main move tonight will be h3 however I
do want to briefly mention this maneuver
and although this opening doesn't really
have a name it's kind of like the the
Seamus Kings Indian where white would
have already played f3 but white is
trying to play without f3 so he can play
f4 and one go so he's just going to
Castle put his knight here and you know
f4 the Queen comes in etc so it's a very
scary and dangerous position and I want
to show you a game but the computers
going to make me go all the way back to
the start because the opening was a
little bit different but this is the
game between luned and Hillier Pearson
from Denmark 2010 and you know four time
will go rather quickly I just want to
get to one key point so a very
interesting transposition to the opening
that we were just looking at
okay Knight f6 we castle castle and so
here was sort of the point after some
normal moves you know whenever they play
a six they pretty much play four and
black goes on preventing you know you'll
notice this these are the maneuvers the
black plays almost every time voice
getting on with his maneuvers so here he
comes you know he's going to get his
pieces out and really attack you so here
and what I like about this game is it
seems like black really understood the
position and he took what was the most
popular move and he really improved upon
it so the most popular move in this
position is Queen c7 and black intends
to get some Queen side
play for example after Queen f3 you push
and then we get our rook in and next
move we play b5 and you get some normal
position for this variation however in
this game black was very clever and he
said I'll just play rook b8 and play the
position without Queen to c7 white went
on with the same thing b5 okay it's a
sacrifice he took and these are the
kinds of sacrifices you do want to look
for because you just want to open the
Queen side up at at all costs before
white does anything in the center and
crushes you and another very good move
c4 yeah fantastic stuff I mean why why
should take it what's going on black
took here and white already made a very
costly blunder he should just move his
bishop back to d3 e2 you know probably
Bishop d3 but he took this which is
actually a mistake because now what did
white black play rook takes yeah and
this already is very good for black and
after taking hopefully we see check and
we pick up the bishop
it is it is like a Kings Indian because
it's a lot like the same ish you know
except for they played f4 and one go
instead of having play f3 and slow play
it and then eventually play out four so
yeah it is it is you know almost
directly a transposition to a Kings
Indian emits wide stroking for an
improved version and here already is in
trouble so I mean we'll go through the
rest of the game even though it's not as
important but okay he tried it here and
blacks just better it's a very strange
imbalance here another nice move h5 I
want to play h4 and undermined your
control over efore so he went for I mean
yes is just something active this
doesn't work but you should try
something so he went in for this
sacrifice and black was happy to trade
and after a few you know really nice
moves eventually he got to a position
where we traded and as opponent had had
enough so that actually the sacrificing
on the queenside even when it you know
gives away upon initially are the kinds
of things that you want to look for in
these positions especially with black
you want to get your counter play as
quickly as possible which often means
you need to sacrifice so here was really
nice the idea c4 with the idea now of
taking back and you you can't take or we
we take and check and pick up the piece
so so it's a very interesting system it
is quite dangerous but for time and we
will have to go all the way back or the
computer won't won't accept what I want
it to do we'll go back to this position
and instead of nigt e2 will look at the
main line here which is h3 and after
castling Knight f3 this is the modern
main line so this is what you can kind
of expect in all of your games except
for not in my experience nobody ever
places they always play like weird stuff
you know the people when I play people
they you know they like to play e4 and
f4 and they want to crush you because
when white plays against this and you
know even a ronin in the press
conference he was like oh yeah you can
play the Pannonia against me every time
yeah I welcome the challenge yet please
always play this and which was also
funny because Fabiana was like yeah I've
been trying for months to play this and
all he's ever allowed it he's like oh
all out every time
so not really when I play this you know
white just tries to crush you
immediately whether it works or not and
here there's actually two moves the most
common move and the most striking is b5
you know it's it looks the nicest and so
this obviously is the kind of thing
you're looking for
but there's one practical downside for
club players it's a draw it's all been
worked out very very complicated lines
sometimes black is just very slightly
worse and so at least a very complicated
game where black is you know just trying
to draw so this is perfect if you want
to study some of the end games that
arise after these positions so you can
get draws against high rated players but
my suspicion is that 99% of the people
that watch my videos are playing you
know and the two one two team
championship and you know they're
playing twelve hundreds and they want to
win every game so it's not you know
super useful press for the crowd so
we'll go kind of quickly even though
this is the main main line and we will
examine some of the consequences there's
two ways to take on b5 the most common
is Knight takes in which is probably the
best but this also leads to an endgame
almost by force but I mean what is
black's next move i mean i will
challenge the class what's the point of
this you know thanks i took a peep on
yeah excellent Knight takes e4 this is
the tactical justification and so after
Knight takes because if you don't I'm
taking you on c3 which could be
problematic check
and okay you can't play Knight to c3
because Bishop takes c3 so you have to
play here and we take this Bishop
preventing castling you can take on d6
you can play here which is better than
Queen D 3 and you'll they'll protect
their Knight and now they can castle and
in positions like this there's lots of
different moves this is a move that
trades a lot this is a move the trades a
lot and they all lead to like different
end games and they're very you know you
can study these in it it would only take
you animal
I don't know how long it takes you guys
a study but a night a week you know a
month and then you could play this and
you could get all sorts of draws with
high rated players and feel great about
yourself if that's that's the kind of
thing you want to do but uh okay it's
not it's not for most people I don't
think but we will return to this
position and we'll look at here which is
White's better try and here there's
already an interesting question for
black we have this tactic we can take
here and then play rook e8 or we can
play rook e8 first and then take on e4
and I'll ask the audience which way
would you guys prefer because there's a
modern consensus yeah yeah which is
correct rook e8 first is correct though
understanding why is very difficult I
mean here this looks great okay and now
I play rook e8 and it's worth noting
this move which also seems crazy and
complicated point being you can go back
and then I take here but uh I mean now
if you take on c3 I played Bishop d2 so
here and something like this should
actually be quite good for white if
white finds the move Knight to g5 and
the point is after you retreat I can go
here and then I can go here and your
dark squares are weak so this actually
is really good for white but going back
I don't have to check you with the Queen
display rookie aid but now this move
Knight g5 so for a long time this this
was unknown white was castling or
playing something else but this move
sort of caused a lot of problems for
black and what's interesting is okay now
we should play here after this there's a
sacrifice that actually occurs in a lot
of lines in the Benoni the idea is when
you have a pond here and your knight can
go to e6 there's often the sacrifice
because taking opens up the black King
immediately there's some interference
and best line is the check take take
again try not to let them castle and you
can even go into this end game which is
kind of shocking because it's you know
the best move here is actually here if
you take here like it's a good position
just after taking I'm attacking the rook
on a8 okay but I take here and you're
pinned you can go here and I don't want
to lose my my rook so I can sacrifice
but this endgame should be slightly
better for white and okay so I mean you
can go here but if you ever take this
then one of my rooks comes over and I
start taking stuff to just the king is a
little bit closer and I can get his
rooks in faster so you can play this way
and then you know you're like a little
bit a little bit better as white but
we're turning to a arjan's move which is
the better move I'm sorry if we just go
back to the night takes line rook e8
this is this is the best move and
normally they Castle though they have
tried here where both of these captures
are actually quite interesting and
they're both complicated and you can
study this forever but uh rook e8
castles and we'll just show the
theoretically best moves and in a
position like this okay and you go back
or you can play here
going back also leads to some
interesting
but okay for time we'll just show this
this line and if you're interested in
playing these you know crazy wild
complicated lines I encourage you to do
it you know they're very very sharp and
this is like all forced have been played
before so you know we could go through
this for hours and hours but uh and you
know equal that so that's that's that's
the consensus which is why I don't think
it makes a whole lot of sense to you
know really sit here and focus all of
our attention on the move b5 I will show
though there's also the modern mainline
with instead of b5 the move a6 and this
is more complicated and you know it's
not completely worked out to a draw yet
so this is worth playing now after a for
the almost automatic response we can
check out this move which was played in
the game but I'll have to out to figure
out what the game was just give me just
a second there was it was a game between
lobelia Vic and T'Pol off from 2003 that
I want to finish the day with here and
this game was played in a the amber
rapid blind tournament so both players
were blindfolded and they're playing
really fast so mistakes were made but
when these people are blindfolded and
they're playing really fast they make
mistakes that most Club players play you
know just regularly with our eyes open
and lots of time in that game
rookie eight was played so this is what
will check out it is worth mentioning
the main line here in this version which
could be very similar to what what the
game was and again black goes about
maneuvering his pieces to prevent the e5
push that's that's what he does and
after here you know you're tacking the
pond you can defend it and what's
interesting here is you'll notice in
this line the bishop has had time to
retreat that'll be a little bit
different than our game and okay so the
main line just continues and they take
and you know all sorts of stuff like
this happens so this is just sort of
generally the main line so we'll try to
understand now
let's see if we can go back to the game
where rookie eight was played which is
also a very common move and very
sensible and after castling he went here
you could also have played here and
transposed to the main line but this is
a very interesting idea that I also
wanted to highlight the move Knight to
h5 is often very useful for a blacken
and some lines they actually play it
really really early in the variation
which has the key point that you're
preventing the Bishop from going to f4
and especially when they've already
played h3 sometimes they haven't played
h3 so you wait to do it until they put
their Bishop on f4 but now if the bishop
gets to go to f4 it'll have a retreat
square so playing this immediately makes
a lot of sense and in response to this
move that was played in the game you
have this idea Bishop to f6 which may
seem a little abnormal if you're
unfamiliar with the variation because
normally when you know you have your
Bishop here this fianchettoed and
awesome you don't think about trading it
away and I even know there was one
player that used to come to the club all
the time he was 1600 and when he had
this bishop you'd never trade it away
for anything like nothing especially
like sometimes there's a rook hanging
here he's like no like neo if it's you
take the rook and they take with the
Queen even if it's the best move he
would never do it you know he was really
is really dogmatic about keeping that
that bishop he's like oh it's worth a
lot more than a rook and even in a rated
game I was playing against him and I
knew that like if he took my rook it was
some position like that where you could
take a rope and I'd take back and be
just be down in exchange if I played it
against some cuz I'd never take it so so
I won that game no you didn't take it
but yeah in it's actually quite normal
if white does decide to chop it in this
position here we can go here and there's
actually some black squares the black
might be able to exploit so okay why can
can trade these bishops but now the
Knights going down for although looking
at this now what happens if white goes
here now then I'm confused
alright cuz I'm thinking about like this
and which I assume was like fine but
it's this interesting idea I guess but
ok so that these sort of complicated
things might happen in the game though
they okay I thought I thought they
repeated a whole bunch of times here but
I guess not you went back and now here
just the normal move and there's another
interesting idea that happens here after
G 4 I have to fianchetto my knight which
is sort of strange and I probably won't
have done what white did now he played
g5 which makes certain people shake
their heads in the audience I probably
keep my pawn here because now my knight
can't go anywhere but he pushed and this
is a very interesting decision the black
has to make you know where do you want
to put your bishop in the game he went
to e7 which is is decent but there is
always this idea to keep in mind in
these sorts of positions and in the
Benoni in general the idea of putting
your bishop on d4 you own as a sacrifice
this is sort of a recurring tactical
theme that might happen and okay maybe
you're saying well happens if I just
snatched this right I mean that seems to
make a lot of sense but if you take back
here you've undefended your G pond and
you can actually go here and you know if
we trade the end games actually you know
quite equal but perhaps I should play
Queen h6 and not trade and make sure my
knight can always get out but something
like this should just be equal and
perfectly playable and it's just sort of
an idea that will recur in these these
lines but he went back and okay you drop
this bishop back you know cuz Black's
about to play Knight to e5 black
immediately undermines the Kings side
and I think black is starting to think I
can't want to get at that loose King you
know maybe the white king is going to be
weak in some of these positions and here
he probably should have just played the
move h4 and kept that pawn there because
it's really restricting some of the
black pieces but he took
and you see you have to decide how you
want to take back and one way is a lot
better than the other it's all about
controlling a five
that's what blacks play is all about so
I assume that gave you the answer yeah
yeah because if a knight takes you have
to worry about a five such sacrifices
but just keeping control over a five is
the is the way to go here he went back
which is a bit of a mistake he's
obviously going to see four that's his
main plan in this whole opening but he's
running away from the king there's not a
lot of defense will black be able to
muster up enough soldiers to go in and
attack way it should be four and here
white again made a mistake he just
played Knight to c4
interestingly enough you should probably
just go back to f3 even if it's
initially you know a sacrifice
yeah computers like you know you need
some pieces by your king
another interesting mistake that wasn't
played is taking which will highlight
some of the things that are going on in
this position well there's not a great
place for your knight to retreat now so
something like this you know even if you
just saw this you'd be like okay this
doesn't make a lot of sense and then the
combination of Knight to e5 and Queen to
h4 lead to a very promising attack for
black and if here which is a mistake I
would like to challenge the class to one
more I'm a little tactical puzzle here
what is the only winning move for black
there's only one yeah excellent
Bishop h3 and the point is if you take
here double question mark yeah Queen g5
and do you have what it takes to
checkmate man who can checkmate me
check with the rope you can you can do
faster you can do even faster here you
know you're letting me block a little
bit and I'm going to start to run away
don't let me run away Arjun Queen h4
excellent move and yeah now you're
getting mated that's checkmate yeah
question okay sergeant did not come up
with that idea on his own okay he heard
it from the audience you're very honest
though that's good
so going back okay he didn't he didn't
take the bishop he played Knight to c4
but no K you run away from the king so
now the knight jumps in here no question
mark and we'll get to the conclusion
here he took took back with the Queen
question mark yeah everybody shaking
their heads how could they play so bad
aren't they looking at the board okay
check and here you know a fantastic
finish was missed which is
understandable because this is really
hard so this is probably the hardest
tactic to find in the whole lecture so I
give you one more chance and you at home
can pause your video we'll see if
anybody here in the audience is a
imaginative enough to come up with the
the right solution here
Queen f4 you checked me I check me I
hate getting checked I guess I go here
unless except for this was played in the
game and you know okay he went he went
to g2 we're looking if you're just
joining us for an amazing tactic yeah
Dani Machuca Dani Machuca okay so I take
any or again you have to find another
really brilliant move
does anybody other than Danny see the
brilliant follow up
yeah 9h five and this just leads to bad
news this is obviously a big threat and
even if you take this I still have a
queen at night so I should be able to
checkmate you something like this and
I'll get where if you go here Queen h3
and like I said anywhere else here
you're just getting mated okay so that
would just lead directly to mate but
that was missed I know you must think
it's embarrassing but they were
blindfolded so give him a break you know
yeah that's okay so in the game your
move was played Queen a4 and then I
guess they're pros so they repeat it a
little bit and then black played this
move which is bad but he still has a
nice position so I miss the immediate
knockout rook comes in yeah we got some
defense he's just going to use all his
pieces he's gonna bring his other Brooke
in and in this position he took and
black missed a very nice win instead he
just took this but he could have done
this check which wins immediately
because if here you take this and if you
go to h1 then Queen f3 followed by mate
and if you go here I can take your rook
I can even play rook to f8 but okay
taking your rook is insufficient and
instead he took the bishop also this is
very good for black he went here here
here question mark and one last move you
need to find if you want to win this
game okay we are at a time so I'll give
you the very last one you can you can
pause at home if you you want to solve
it by yourself but in this position
black played Bishop to g4 I mean yeah so
yeah if you you can't really take the
bishop and I'm about to play Bishop to
f3 so I played f3 himself but okay the
simplest taking what's played and now
yet to find one more move but I think
for these players that people with their
eyes closed it's sort of routine you can
win material by checking and trading
lots of stuff so here white resigned
without training Queens or anything but
uh yeah so it was just hopefully that
showed you some of the the common ideas
here in the main line of the modern
benoni as I said next week we will go
over the fianchetto variation and
hopefully if his parent is okay with it
we'll have our gin here tomorrow night
we've got a very special deal for our
gym so hopefully we see you guys
tomorrow night and until then like share
subscribe and thanks everybody for
coming out